So we have three approved Bispecific for multiple myeloma targeting BCMA and then
a couple in the pipeline, a couple that didn't make it, but these are in the relapsed refractory
setting.
So we want to know, can we move these up front and exploit the benefits, but understand the
safety concepts related to these bispecifics and the upfront treatment of multiple myeloma?
This is obviously not an exhaustive list of all the trials that are ongoing.
Look at BCMA bispecifics and multiple myeloma.
These are the three buckets that I think of with upfront treatment of multiple myeloma.
Transplant eligible as induction, transplant ineligible.
Now, is this going to be ongoing treatment till progression, or is this going to be time
limited treatment?
And then for the, while it's still on life support, post-transplant maintenance with
Bispecific in the time limited setting.
There's some interesting concepts that we should look at here as well.
The risks of infections in a patient population that we might have a higher bar for.
The health of the T cells as these patients will be untreated and how that might translate
to CRS and ICANN's risk.
And then should we be demanding more quads for comparator arms in some of the larger
trials now that we've seen some of the Cepheus and MRAS data supporting that in basically
transplant and transplant ineligible studies.
We have some preliminary data from some of the studies that have been presented over
the past couple of years.
This is the Majestic 5 trial.
Looking at TEC-based induction therapy prior to transplant, looking at three arms with
DR plus TEC or DVR plus TEC, followed by transplant, followed by TEC-dera maintenance for 18 cycles.
And the gist of it was that as far as toxicity goes, there was some hematologic toxicity,
predominantly neutropenia that seemed to be time limited.
Vortezomib did not increase the risk of this hematologic toxicity.
CRS occurred at probably about the same rate.
The same rate that we see in the relapse refractory setting in two thirds of patients, but no
grade three or four CS, no ICANN's occurred.
There were no grade five AEs and there were no grade five infections or discontinuation
related to infections.
So we've gotten better at managing the infectious toxicities with prophylaxis and IVIG
supplementation.
One of the unique questions in this patient population was how did TEC-based induction
impact stem cell collection and 96% of patients were able to successfully mobilize for at
least one transplant.
And that's what we're looking for in this patient population.
And of course, the response data also brings up a number of other questions because by
the end of induction, the overall response rate was 100% and the MRD negativity rate
was 100%.
So it begs the question, was the transplant even necessary in the first place?
And I think these data are going to be fleshed out over time.
But as far as we're concerned right now, the TEC-based induction was a successful induction
regimen and led to unprecedented responses.
With another DCMA-bispecific, the LINC-MM4 trial looking at both transplant-eligible and
ineligible patients, 62% of patients were transplant-eligible, but of them, 10 out of
28 only went on to stem cell transplant, but all had accessible stem cell yield.
The most common toxicities were hematologic with neutropenia infection occurring in 84%
of patients with 33% grade three.
This is across both the ineligible and eligible.
So we're looking at a lot of different things.
We're looking at a lot of different things.
There's a 44% incidence of CRS, a little bit lower than what is seen with some of
the others, and an 86% overall response rate with patients who received the highest dose
of Linvo achieving 100% MRT negativity rate.
And what was different about that trial was that it was monotherapy as opposed to combination.
There's an ongoing phase three trial with two parts, a dose escalation and dose expansion,
looking at several different cohorts.
And with Elra in combination with their rev and the part one with one of the cohorts looking at Elra plus DR was presented recently last year at ASCO.
And once again, similar theme, CRS occurring in about 62% of patients, but none higher than grade two.
One grade two ICANS and infections tended to occur early and then waned over time, similar with the other BCMA bispecifics.
The responses deepened over time with the 97%.
Uh,
overall response rate and occurred early and maintained over time.
Moving into the post-transplant maintenance setting, the Majestek IV post-transplant using three different arms of Teclen or Tecmonotherapy was presented last year with the safety running cohort.
And this was also for time-limited therapy with up to 26 cycles.
Similar themes here, neutropenia occurs early and is generally manageable.
Uh,
as one would expect the teclistamab dose intensity was much better than that of the LEN patients had to decrease the doses of LEN due to tolerability.
Um,
CRS mainly occurred during the step-up dosing.
And as you see,
the CRS rate was 40 to 50%,
so maybe slightly less than what we see in the induction setting or in the relapse refractory setting.
Um,
there was no greater signal for infection.
Uh,
one patient did pass away from grade five COVID-19.
Um,
most of these patients who were COVID-19,
who were coming from transplant had not achieved to CR going into the maintenance,
uh,
and had not achieved MRD negativity.
And after,
uh,
going,
through teclistamab maintenance or during teclistamab maintenance with various follow-up,
the best response was a hundred,
um,
close to a hundred percent overall response rate across all three arms with a hundred percent MRD negativity rate.
So it's a notable deepening of response and MRD negativity rate in that post-transplant.
So it's a notable deepening of response and MRD negativity rate in that post-transplant setting.
Um,
the ongoing,
uh,
phase three magnetism trial is a phase three trial looking at the same,
cohort.
We're awaiting the data of that.
So I think there are a lot of,
um,
things we can glean from all of these studies so far.
Uh,
it seems that using bispecifics in the upfront setting is,
uh,
safe and tolerable.
We've gotten much better about managing the infectious related toxicities.
There's no increase in the risk of CRS or ICANS as,
uh,
despite the fact that these patients,
these patients are untreated and their T cells are healthier.
Um,
there doesn't seem to be any impact on the ability to collect stem cells if we're using it,
uh,
pre-transplant.
Um,
well,
and,
but the question is whether that will actually matter.
Is this something that's going to make transplant obsolete?
And we see a deepening of response and,
um,
unprecedented MRD negativity for the frontline setting.
We expect that this will translate to PFS and ROS.
Um,
the one wrinkle to that is whether or not this is going to have an impact on the ability of patients to receive BCMA targeting CAR-T cell therapy should they relapse.
but as my uncle Ben said,
with great power comes great responsibility.
Thank you all for your time.
That was a Spider-Man reference.